pop
[Musique]
voyez ce dossier il est accablant j'ai
pas tué jardel chaud sinon si soyeux ça
peut apporter dans lequel fit régionale
as une amie d'enfance
attendent amoureuse de toi non salut
passera pas oublier qu'à l'accès dans la
mode chez les dames aucune besoin de pas
avec le scandale révélé beaucoup
d'humour commis ces crimes parfaits 120
ce site ans à venir qui sera rentable
[Musique]
il
oui
[Musique]
bonjour l'autre une brigitte lequel
elles veulent de bons flux je vais pas
déjà très au dessus du tarif faut se
mettre à leur place briand et
photographes internationaux se disputent
si elle ne fait pas mannequin cabine
avec des horaires fixes
elle se fera facilement 1000 francs par
jour les remplacera en face à brigitte
mais pas having elle est sublime et bien
chouchoutés l'eau et mignotte et va
augmenter là est balancé d'autres
ensuite bat toujours cette embrouille
avec le fabricant damian orange et ça
pour moi je ne veux plus entendre parler
quoi d'autre merci connaître désolé de
l'avoir ici tard vous dites ça tous les
soirs
bonne nuit
elle me
tu es obligé c'est bien j'ai un travail
fou pourquoi se fait en victime aura
même si on sait pas
c'est un peu nettes ne faut jamais sept
ans devait enfin moi ma chérie mon
échéances à préparer crois moi elle est
gratinée sans compter qu'il faut j'ai
plus ce contrat pour new york doit
partir demain matin comme s'ils gagnent
pas encore à cette free pour le fric
jeune homme l'amour c'est alors qu'est
ce qui te reste je ne sais pas moi je
pense à me poser la question
[Musique]
m
au secours
[Musique]
et
mais
oui
[Musique]
et
cette têtu quand même ou alors ici la
contestation c'est râpé tout ce que je
vous demande c'est de répondre oui ou
non à mes questions d'accord et moi tout
ce que je vous demande c'est de pas
répondre à ma place d'accord il est
entré
[Musique]
c'est lui
j'en suis sûr c'est lui
attention madame je ne peux pas
témoignages hâtif les faits remontent à
26 jours réfléchissez bien avant de
parler oui tout votre temps c'est très
grave très c'est saint païen tout cas sa
carrure la chemise en jean et est
châtain il avait les cheveux vais vous
et des gouttes d'eau
marcher jusqu'aux bureaux
salon
on
mais qu'est ce qui vous a fait
au cours de l'été
seuls merci madame
dans sa déposition guyomard
[Musique]
alors vous êtes content tout va bien
pour vous
pas de bêtises a essayé
[Musique]
voyez ce dossier
il est accablant chaque indice chaque
ligne vous désigne comme meurtrier
et pour finir vous êtes formellement
reconnu par un témoin j'ai pas tué
jardel
je jure sur la même marc d'evelyne
lorsque je veux c'est tout reprendre
depuis le début certainement un moment
je me suis trompé
fragments de seconde j'ai pesé dans la
balance sans m'en apercevoir enfin pas
trop le sait tout de même à fort hood se
dire que si ce gosse est innocent et
qu'on condamne ce sera demain mais
qu'est ce que vous racontez la société a
pris toutes les précautions et après le
jus qu'à la chambre les mines réputation
et après la chambre des mises en
accusation il y en avoir un président
zafy et un jury et tous ces gens là
seront une opinion sur mon dossier qu'il
le veuille ou non
écoutez moulin j'ai beaucoup de travail
on parlera de ça une autre fois ce que
vous le voulez bien oui les bijoux de
vacances qui me reste
je peux les prendre maintenant
d'excellentes idées raymond mettre au
vert
[Musique]
quand avez vous appris que votre femme
était l'âme et à ce jeu empreint sa mort
comment l'avez vous allez trouver des
lettres ça chez vous à paris on peut
peut oui les peu ça veut dire les
peupliers dans le patois du pays
s'annonce formidable et les maisons
[Musique]
c'est là que j'ai passé mon enfance d'y
retourner souvent le plus souvent
possible
ce taux peut vous être retiré après
avoir raté votre suicide
j'ai pensé qu'avec là que je pouvais
m'en sortir je devenais fou je
n'arrêtais pas de penser à une jour et
nuit
je me faisais pas de reproche c'est de
ne même pas de votre faute si elle s'est
tuée dans un accident de voiture
l'aviation c'était des lettres de jardel
oui ça m'a presque soulagé je vous
paraître monstrueux non je vous
comprends
est mis sur un piédestal et puis tout
d'un coup tout s'écroulait et ensuite
dans les quatre jours qui ont suivi
cette révélation
je tournais en rond dans la maison seul
évidemment seul je n'ai pas cherché à en
savoir plus sur l'origine gens savaient
bien assez pour mon goût huit mois ça a
duré huit mois
je ne pouvais pas lutter ils avaient
tous jardel il était beau et est riche
et est célèbre
tout ce que je n'avais pensé ou le ici
au peu la haine ça ne dure pas dans un
endroit magique
c'est pour ça que ça a toujours été mon
refuge
la voulais quelque chose
voilà alors pourquoi vous tourner autour
de la maison là a beau comme ça je
promène way à l'est ou à venir où aller
tourner à dix jeux les plus sûrs à 100 m
ouais ouais
il en est des jeunes lieu avant-hier
jeudi dans pour faire des photos de la
maison du meurtrier
bon vous pouvez en faire des photos et
puis vous pouvez me prendre mais aussi
si vous voulez je connais c'est bien tu
le gardien forcément ça vous ennuie les
protéines sont maintenant un petit tour
à l'intérieur ou aux lâchers au tour
donc vous savez ce que c'est l'endroit
où le nôtre il ya des 600 crimes bien
les lecteurs adorent ce genre de détails
on essaie justice passe et j'en ai fait
un petit peu si j'ai juste pour renifler
et nous ne déposerait la clé en partant
ils habitent là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez bien lieu comment se
connaît dans ce métier on s'embrasse on
se déteste on se quitte plus tout ça
mélangé sur l'accident vous étudiez
agricole de spa on était tous là on la
veut présenter la collection au casino
de divonne ça marche du tonnerre au on
était super crevé mais le patron était
content il à payer le champagne quand
eve lyne est parti de là elle était
complètement bourré elle est partisane
oui il habitait un hôtel au dessus de
given dans la montagne il qu'ils
seraient pas les patrons les ailes avant
parce que bruce qui n'est pas entre avec
m à écouter ces gens d'histoire je me
mêle pas parce qu'on passait son temps à
ça enfin si j'ai bien compris
youri du tirage entre c'est pour ça
qu'elle a trop bu et qu'elle est partie
avant tout le monde et qu'elle séduit oh
non il faut pas exagérer si c'est arrivé
c'est que ça devait arriver
je crois au destin moi tout ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'elle n'était pas dans
son état normal
la fatigue la contrariété l'alcool le
lendemain matin quand j'ai appris que sa
voiture avait découché dans un virage
ça m'a pas tellement surprise ouvrir les
jardins
pourquoi jardel il était temps mais le
malheureux javel emmerder ça oui parce
qu'on avait un autre gars là trois jeux
plus tard a menti car nous manque et
mannequin sans compter qu'il a fallu qui
s'occupe de tout
la morgue les obsèques enfin vous voyez
avec votre famille si je mens même
téléphoné à bernard vernon bassan mari
parce que les des mariés ouais mais avec
un détachement chouette on battre pour
être talent est-ce qu'il n'est pas
intéressé sa fin il était dans le virage
complet paraît qu'elle a essayé de se
tuer il se ratait de peu et quand il a
fait surface
tout était déjà réglé c'était plus un
thème qui se dérangent
[Musique]
ça c'est pour ma tante est née au
lendemain du rejet la cuisine de famille
ici si vous voulez quelque chose de
spécial dans lequel d'entre nous en
espérant que cette augmentation
n'interviendra pas très prochainement du
nouveau dans la cage jardel le délai de
garde à vue étant écoulé le dossier a
été transmis au parquet par le
commissaire moulin le juge senard a
aussi des inculpés bernard de fou
d'homicide volontaire sur la personne du
couturier pierre jardel
voici enfin terminer une affaire qui
depuis 25 jours mobilisé l'attention
générale c'était un drôle de type
semble enfermé et puis tout va commencer
pourquoi ils se mettaient à paris on
pouvait plus l'arrêter
ouais ouais on est un vrai grâce
qu'est-ce qui l'a vu faire des choux
il ya longtemps que vous le connaissiez
berne un bond depuis qu'il est tout
petit puis il a fallu qu'il aille vivre
à paris ça lui a pas porté bonheur
moi j'ai mon idée là dessus aussi
il est innocent qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire ça c'est pendant 69 jours gentil
toujours par le service minimum tout
c'est un rêve est en tout cas si
l'inculpé 6-4 même des raisons je vais
vous les 10 rebonds et raison pendant
près d'un mois la police à mr doyer avec
une personnalité comme jardel
protestions juste une éponge il fallait
absolument un coupable
alors ils ont fabriqué mais c'est
classique on a vu ça sans point que ce
que vous racontez ya des charges
accablantes contre lui
et si elles sont tellement accablant ne
sont pas compris la page ou non sont
pourtant pas de cadeaux aussi sound
flics les coups dans la gueule
les interrogatoires des nuits entières
là tout nu au milieu de la pièce et plus
dirigistes beau on lui c'est un faible
il a eu quelque chose à se reprocher il
n'aurait jamais tenu le coup dudon pop
d'utiliser les passages à tabac ça
n'existe plus depuis longtemps
aaaaah d'autres détails pourquoi
voulez-vous brutalisé un suspect alors
que tous l'accusent le mobile l'arme du
crime pas d'alibi et pour finir il est
formellement reconnu par un témoin vous
pouvez me raconter ce que vous voulez on
ne tue pas un homme sous prétexte qu'on
a découvert que dans le temps il a été
l'amant de votre femme qui est morte
depuis un mois mais ça tient pas debout
c'est du roman ils nous prennent
vraiment pour des cons
bon d'accord
alors si c'est pas lui qui s je sais pas
cambrioleur il y avait 5 millions
d'euros on n'est pas touché
les expertises psychiatriques est ce que
vous en faites cyclothymique jaloux
suicidaire le profil type du meurtrier
passionnel
[Musique]
vous avez l'air drôlement ou non mais
moi je
j'ai lu les journaux comme tout le monde
ah bon
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
un peu tourmenté
est ce qu'on peut
[Musique]
et c'est là qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est
mon diplôme de karaté
d'être 3e dan bravo mais j'ai pas dit ça
n'avait pas demandé pourquoi ça vous
intéresse je pense bien que ça
m'intéresse voilà un t2 suis c'est
sûrement ce que c'est à coups portés
avec le côté des points comme ça c'est
méchant comme le coup en principe ça
provoque l'éclatement de la partie
touchée ah oui c'est méchant il que shu
c'est la première vertèbre cervicale un
endroit particulièrement vulnérables des
13 points vitaux mais à l'entraînement
quand tu mets ses couleurs à
l'entraînement peut-être mais dans une
bagarre supposons vous êtes menacés par
quelqu'un tient à un revolver ils tirent
sur vous un troisième dan sait capable
de parer le coup non en principe oui
comment cela par exemple par un taillis
sabah qui suivit d'un maire guiri pays
ses béquilles qu'est ce que c'est c'est
une forme d steve suivie d'un coup de
pied qui déséquilibrent adversaires et
éventuellement suivi d'un bruit
[Musique]
il luttera lise et alors là le bus il se
retrouve à la morgue
pourquoi vous me demandez tout ça il ya
neuf chances sur dix pour que jardel et
été tué d'un coup de pied raté un coup
qui exige une grande précision qui
suppose un long entraînement qui ne peut
être porté que par un champion un 3e dan
par exemple j'avais compris que c'était
pas la peine de vous donner tous mal
dites moi le karaté
ça donne une formidable maîtrise de swan
pourquoi est-ce que je l'aurais tué
gerbail m'avancer à quoi les raisons ne
manquent pas il avait été le mauvais
génie de votre femme vous l'avez prise
deux fois somme toute une fois en
devenant son amour et une autre fois en
étant indirectement responsable de sa
mort ouais enfin je vous ferai remarquer
que je ne suis tout de même pas le seul
3e dan qui se trimballe dans la nature
ça compte ou non pas les roms vous savez
par votre femme que jardel convié toutes
les nuits
vous savez aussi que jusqu'à 6 ans
n'importe qui peut s'introduire dans les
bureaux en passant inaperçu dans le
va-et-vient général vous était donc
facile de vous cacher la dompter 60
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
où
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors comment guillaume martet encore au
lit à 5 heures du matin t'as pas honte
ainsi trois patrons au studio occupe à
ta femme et potins bon demandent lui
demander ici peut arriver qu'une jeune
femme qui a les cheveux courts porte des
épingles à cheveux tu hésites pas de
cheveux bons à 30 secondes et
et qu'est ce qui a donc est ce qu'on
peut faire a les cheveux courts et
portait des épingles à cheveux
c'est quoi des épingles à cheveux
mais quoi des épingles à cheveux quand
on a les cheveux courts
est ce qu'on peut en mai e n est pas
bien réveillé bon bah c'est fait rien tu
vas mon asservissement
tu vas aller la maison de couture de
jaar d'aller interroger de personnes
j'aurais savoir si levin de fou à porter
les cheveux longs à une époque de sa vie
et aussi si elle était blonde huile
dossiers transmis au parquet ça ne nous
concerne plus attendu pas c'est pas
réguliers vers une nouvelle commission
rogatoire là à coup de fouet à la paix
était fou de moi la réponse à une heure
aux étoiles font aux 47 94 70 94 tu
n'obtiens pas le 15 47 94 70 comprend un
gain dans le qu'un gamin tu demanderas
monsieur guillaume à monsieur qui
monsieur guy marc comme ça se prononce
en vain ya main
qui c'était c'est le patron il va pas
bien du tout d'or hu
[Musique]
[Rires]
en on sait quand tu as assez naturel
tous les cas j'aurais pensé dans ma
clientèle ces des cheveux de jeune fille
moi c'est surtout les femmes que je
crois même qu'elle voudrait bien l'avoir
de pareilles et d'après vous il ya
longtemps qu'ils sont tombés
longtemps la gaine est encore soyeuse la
racine et gras sauf disons pas plus de
deux mois
[Musique]
il est arrivé quand tu donnes se fiche
bien c'est plus commode pour moi je vous
dit il par un prêt de la nuit quand je
me suis levé ce matin à 6h le verrou
était pas tiré je cocula l'oubli je veux
rentrer à peu près 20 minutes plus tard
il monte tout de suite dans sa chambre
sans rien n'est pas votre problème
il est ressorti après dans la matinée
bon jeu
je reçus un monsieur pourriez vous nous
montrez vos papiers s'il vous plaît mais
j'ai pas sûrement vous pouvez aller les
chercher avec plusieurs permettez que je
fis ce serait dommage de laisser
refroidir bon mais prendra bien quelque
chose non non merci
sourire j'ai bien compris donc vous êtes
bien monsieur guyomard oui mais c'est
sarah ingénieurs ingénieurs ingénieurs
journalistes journalistes
mais oui j'en ali c'est bien ce que vous
avez déclaré au gardien des peu un oui
bien sûr et passer la nuit là haut dans
la maison
pourquoi vous sais rien d'inscrit aussi
écouter monsieur on n'est pas là pour
rigoler nous on a autre chose à faire
[Musique]
oui mais ce que j'ai une seconde je vous
prends sa cabine à la hausse du coût de
1 à jamais des bains mais jamais échoué
bon bah ça m'arrange d'accord merci
on avait demandé mes papiers oui tiens
aussi à vous excuser moi je me sers aux
états unis bon allez on se le boisseau
bon alors là volontiers à l'horizon
alors comme ça vous venez passez vos
vacances chez nous oui et alors si vous
avez la pêche
vous pourriez peut-être non un service à
votre disposition voilà je cherche une
jeune fille
enfin je suppose que les jeunes en tout
cas elle est blonde très blond avec des
cheveux longs en bas des cheveux blancs
jusqu'au coude
c'est la fille l'oiseau la fille du
verrat juste mais alors elle les a
coupés à la salle ja ah bon je savais
pour un choix pour qui ça peuvent être
envoyées par quelques petits détails
supplémentaires de données pour qu'on
puisse les situer dans un peu mieux non
non je sais enfin des cheveux blonds
soyeux ça passe pas inaperçu alors je
vois guère que la petite désert beau à
oui la fille du colonel je pensais pas
oui c'est la fille des herbes ou y'a pas
de problème d zerbo ancien moniteur du
cadre noir de saumur quai de loire de la
cavalerie française d'origine
est-ce que tu as donné à manger aux
poules est capable d'être à la fois pour
la q2 to be cible mais l'appeler j'ai
dit là j'étais dans l'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
oui
[Musique]
allez casser le nez le dire vous et même
aujourd'hui
bonjour je désirerais voir mademoiselle
votre fille elle n'y est pas là c'est à
quel sujet
c'est personnel je suis son père et les
mineurs et le droit de savoir et
j'entends comme entre temps elle ne
rentre pas elle est en voyage on y est
vous je suis un ami de bernard de fou
n'est pas petit petit petit petit petit
on pouvait du petit petit petit petit
gars mais titi est encore là le manquez
pas oui mais bernard vous convient-il
pas retourne dans ta chambre
immédiatement
toi tu me le dira et m'a échappé
ils ont besoin en prison ses portes
jusqu'à 3 2
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est en nous efforçant mais faire de
vivre encore plus chrétiennement nous
mettrons en pratique les paroles que
nous a laissé le seigneur jésus âme
[Musique]
d'autant
demain
je suis ton
[Musique]
ah ah
à
[Musique]
c'est mon jour
il titre
suis commissaire de police
la ceinture de sécurité qu'est ce que
c'est que ça la ceinture de sécurité
qu'est ce que c'est et c'est obligatoire
vous saviez pas de cette ficelle
maucoronel le second fera les
territoires et aussi je ne roule jamais
la nuit vous n'allez pas me faire rater
la messe à cause de ces bêtises
oh là là vos pneus sont usés à 75% alors
ça c'est un record arrivé ici
tellement désespérée je me suis occupée
[Musique]
je lui apporte à manger en empêcher
sinon ce serait laisser mourir
[Musique]
j
demont
c'est tout ce que j'ai faudra vous en
compte entier alors par deux ceintures
de sécurité pas d'assurance pas de
m'être fait tellement porté sur moi pour
vous c'est aller dans mon rapport
pour l'instant c'est moi qui vais vous
savez mon colonel et avec tout le
respect que je vous dois vous risquez
gros c'est vous qui est si gros vous me
fait rater la messe vous risquez l'enfer
pour commencer le mobile ne tient plus
il avait tout ce qu'il faut sous la main
pour changer les idées le pépère il
avait aucune raison d'aller tuer jardel
part j'aime aussi beaucoup de tactique
pas parler de cette petite obole
je voulais pas la mettre dans le coup il
espérer s'en sortir tout seul pas
oublier qu'à l'accès dans la môme chez
les dr beau plaisante pas avec le
scandale
la preuve quand il a appris
l'inculpation de bernard le vieux il a
commencé par la séquestrer et dont on ne
trouve pas ça un peu bizarre toi comment
tu penses que je mets dans un accident
qu'elle soit si désespérée que tu
essaies de te tuer un seul pourra bien
ressembler oui voilà quinze jours après
tu tombe amoureux d'une autre fille qui
ça moi oui mais non mais t'es peut-être
amour avant j'ai compris du coup ils se
suicident abat son suicide
j'ai ma petite idée là-dessus seulement
elle est tellement tordu que je préfère
pas en parler
enfin pas encore surtout à toi bon alors
le juge
juge cravate sombre et chemise blanche
ils ont ils à tous les racoins à non non
pas tout non parce que s'ils en venaient
aux mêmes conclusions que moi le bernard
il le garde et moi ce que je veux c'est
qu'il me le rendent donc on va peut-être
choses à se dire tous les deux nous en
parler un retrait ce commissaire le
mobile enfin le juge il n'y a pas que le
mobile qui tombent ainsi s'est toujours
refusé à me donner un alibi pour le soir
du crime
or la petite venait de rejoindre chaque
soir s'ils n'en a pas parlé c'est pour
son père de la bonne foi que ça me
paraît un peu gros un peu gros et en
même temps un peu légers moins chers
messieurs vous ne trouvez pas enfin je
veux dire votre votre façon de procéder
car enfin vous ne m'apportait rien
aucune piste officielle dans une
déposition seulement le résultat d'une
sorte d' enquête personnelle menée à
titre privé avouez que c'est une
procédure peu ordinaire oui mais lorsque
vous aurez prononcer non lieu il sera
toujours temps de reprendre des choses à
zéro
si ça ne vous fait rien j'aimerais que
vous me laissiez le soin de décider s'il
veut voir prononciez de non lieu ou pas
jusqu'à nouvel ordre c'est moins celui
chargé de l'instruction
jardel écrire des lettres d'amour la
meilleure de la journée
moi j'ai dit que vignes que passait la
robe de mariée il n'y a pas à revenir là
dessus il me dérangeait pas choquer
excusez moi vous disiez eh oui si
bernard avait inventé ces lettres
c'est peut-être pour nous faire croire
qu'il a appris l'infidélité de sa femme
après la mort de jarden et par là même
dissimulé qu'il était déjà au courant
avant et alors et alors dans l'hypothèse
d'un meurtre passionnel s'il était déjà
au point un bon ballon at il dit après
suis pas très bien commencé à m'en fait
de toute façon il l'a tué alors qu'est
ce que ça change
j'ai pas d'option de pardon vous je me
suis le commissaire bonjour je voudrais
m'excuser une seconde je n'ai pas la
moindre intention de passer leurs robes
de mariées et d'une et d'ailleurs je ne
passerai aucune robe cette collection
sont toutes à chier ça suffit comme ça
avec venait pas travailler ici vous
n'avez qu'à demander votre compte sorti
il ya peut-être notre solution 1
ça c'est le genre d'incident qui se
produit quotidiennement dans notre
métier on se défonce
même si on est sur les lèvres dit
n'importe quoi
finalement tout se passe très bien 11
parties à jouer la succession d'un homme
comme aux ardennes et que vous ne pensez
je comprends bien maintenant c'est vous
qui tenez tout en main
la maison a été décapitée du jour au
lendemain j'ai été chargé dans la sueur
et la bonne marche
chargé par qui peuls avaient pris des
dispositions testamentaires dans ce sens
on se doutait qu au cas où il
disparaîtrait sa mort risque est à néant
chômage 800 personnes et en outre il
avait eu à coeur d'assurer la continuité
de son havre et de son style et vous
étiez certainement la personne n'a pu
désigner pour ça ça ne s'est pas tout
cas c'est ce qu'ont pensé les
commanditaires en d'autres termes c'est
vous qui a hérité de la faire non pas
exactement je suis seulement gérante
les trois sociétés seulement c'est une
jolie promotion
ah oui qu'il est heureux que nous ayons
des jungles vous avez beaucoup d'humour
commissaire un coupable désigné par vous
d'ailleurs que vous avez identifié sans
la moindre hésitation
vous avez crié c'est lui avant même de
le regarder titre que j'ai fait un faux
il faut croire puisqu'il est innocent et
nasa
comment sinon merci madame pourquoi tu
m'as pas laissé continuer je suis pas si
tu as marqué mais depuis le début de
cette affaire on a déjà fait un nombre
impressionnant de faux pas nous c'est ça
qui a fait une enquête
une succession de conneries jusqu'au
jour où on s'aperçoit qu'il y en a une
qui a un peu moins concluants n'ont
rentré à paris que vous êtes devenu
détective privé maintenant si vous avez
fait pression sur un juge d'instruction
à titre personnel pour obtenir la relève
d'un accusé vous vous prenez pour robin
des bois et enfin comble de tout vous
permettez de formuler les soupçons très
graves sans apporter l'ombre d'une
preuve à l'endroit d'un témoin
parfaitement autonome
de quoi trouver delvaux qui a des
relations vivre et où et ce n'est pas
tout deux quotidiens du matin il fait
allusion
en attendant les hebdomadaires en fin de
semaine on va encore attendre la bonne
vieille chanson sur la police qui outre
passé 3 qui menacent la vie privée des
citoyens
encore un succès sur succès qu'est ce
qu'on me reproche son drama mercier au
contraire je repars à zéro une enquête
dont je n'étais pas cette 6e rang
derrière et où la mieux je vous interdis
de blues occupent d'affaires jardin
tente à titre officiel qu'un titre est
privé donc coûté patron décembre
d'ailleurs j'ai un autre travail pour
accuse qu'on a sauté en flagrant délit
dans un bureau à plus de 500 regard du
soir un cambrioleur a trouvé sa survie
flagrant délit ce que je sens effet
interrogé bien pu faire dans n'importe
quel loupé peut soit georges tin jeu
c'est un travail mineur il n'est pas à
la mesure du grand du subtil du s'agace
commissaire moulin un peu ça va merci
j'ai compris une manière de me faire
partir du bas de l'échelle
prenez le comme vous voudrez d'oublier
le dossier et jetez donc un coup d'oeil
sur la photo anthropométrique que vous
intéressera sûrement
ah ah je vous ai bien l avouer que
c'était pas mal joué ma petite comédie
elle est maintenant mon vieux au boulot
un peu ferme hans a dit dans c'est vous
qui l'avez fabriquer je n'ai jamais vu
de pareil dit j'aime pas beaucoup parler
tout seul alors supposons que c'est une
phrase vous en dit une autre ça fait ce
qu'on appelle une conversation en
principe c'est comme ça que ça se passe
chez gens bien élevés nous bon alors
notre spécialité c'est vous introduire
la nuit dans les bureaux des chefs
d'entreprise de préférence en fin de
mois au cas où l'argent de la paix y
traîne dans un coin c'est bien ça ma
spécialité pas pousser c'est arrivé une
fois c'est tout dans vous non plus faut
pas pousser
lors de votre première déposition vous
avez bien dos et le cou de la ceca fin
mars
disons que c'est arrivé deux fois une 3
ok je l'avais dit
et ce à quoi ça vous servez avec un
revolver je comprendrais on eût surpris
on braque ça intimide une matraque
j'ai jamais vu personne n'avait les
branchements une matrone on idée c'est
au camp menacerait permettait de me
dégager
oui ça vous rassurer vous avez des mots
de toute façon ne sera pas servi ça on
peut jamais ça suppose
vous êtes surpris par quelqu'un il
thibout mme nada un revolver et même
temps il dire sur supposons toujours
niveau at avant d'être candidat au
second prénom grâce à ça vous pouvez
neutraliser vite fait bien fait il
suffit je pas moins un petit coup sur la
nuque
par exemple nous avons dit
h&m en fait pourquoi je vous dis ça
attendez voir qu'est-ce qui a pu me
faire penser à ça mais c'est vrai que je
suis mais c'est le meurtre du couturier
paul jardel première vertèbre cervicale
écrasé cette l1 on petit dans quelle
coïncidence
le 30 juillet la fin du mois là aussi
qu'est ce que vous racontez là j'ai rien
à voir avec ça moi le meurtrier on
l'arrêté non je sais c'est même moi
c'est moi l'ennui c'est qu'il n'a jamais
avoué j'ai dû me tromper
un garçon comme vous avec des cheveux
longs comme vous chemise jean comme vous
et pas d'alibi à redon pardon
j'étais pas à paris j'étais chez la mère
dans le nord et ça vous pouvez lui
demander quel jour le 30 juin
comment est ce que vous savez que c'est
elton john jordan été tués c'est vous
qui venez de le dire
non moi j'ai dit le 30 juillet mais
c'est vous qui avez raison
c'était bien le temps de jeu
et tu vas être sue
je le pense oui on va vous dire et tout
ça au juge d'instruction
j'avale quoi t'as pas pris les cinq
breaks qui se trouvait sur le bord on
s'écoute mankita filet l'échelon de
panique à ce point ça m'aurait vraiment
arrangé moi que tu les problèmes tu vois
ça m'aurait fait gagner du temps
[Musique]
salut
m
passé dans le quartier
je ramène alors pas la peine
j'ai envie de marcher bernard je
comprends que vous en ayez gros sur la
patate mais je ne souhaite même pas mal
démener pour réparer les erreurs
bon je voulais vous dire en ce qui
concerne la petite gêne nous avons dit
si les procureurs et moi nous ne parlons
pas des gens mais il s'en sort
je sais l'importance que c'est la bonne
merci pour tout et monsieur le
commissaire et encore bravo
à
ce soir jarreau ça ne décroît pas si ça
vous dit à 8 heures chez moi
[Musique]
il fallait pas tout ce qu'il faut pour
les mettre au frais mais dites moi vos
amis sont pas encore arrivés non
finalement ils viennent pas ah bon et
pourquoi pas peut-être parce que je les
ai pas invité envie de rester un peu
tranquille à mai alors je vous dérange
vous
non pas du tout vous c'est pas pareil je
préparais un petit casse-croûte whisky
savoie dont je me mets à votre santé
et pourquoi moi c'est pas pareil oh ils
ont j'avais envie de parler pas
n'importe qui
entre vous et moi des rapports passent
un peu comme un psychanalyste et son
patient c'est con non
non c'est pas à six il suffit de choisir
un policier comme confident c'est
essentiellement con non mais je suis pas
ici un policier quand est-ce que vous
retournez beaucoup vous voyez ça
recommence couasnon les questions on
pouvait pas vous empêcher de poser des
questions c'est une vraie maladie dans
votre femme elle doit pas se marrer tous
les jours je suis pas marrer un bon hein
comment tu as fait non mais je suis pas
un cadeau à faire à une femme on
travaille m'absente tellement quand je
suis sur un coup j'y pense jour et nuit
je veux plus la bouche même pour manger
un peu plus oublier d'inspirer la
solitude du grand flic c'est beau ça ces
boulevards
manse j'en ai pris goût aussi une époque
j'étais en pleine déprime n'arrivais
plus à dormir reste une vraie saloperie
avec ça que j'essaie de me [ __ ] en
l'air
je crois que vous avez ouvert le gaz de
la cuisinière
vous savez le gaz les compris mais j'ai
pas fait le détail on avait pris
beaucoup [ __ ] la boîte une autre boîte
monsieur le commissaire mois
vous avez des chances que les concierges
arrivée n'a pas été simple
au fait pour que les montées
le ralliement de tous les matins à 8h un
peu tôt pour mon goût mais enfin c'est
le seul moment de la journée où elle est
libre pour faire le ménage et c'est vous
qui lui ouvrait non non non à la clé et
vous voulez pas les copains mais alors
votre suicide
ouais c'était pas de soi maintenant là
j'ai jamais dit que tel soit à part dont
je me souviens très bien
vous avez appris l'accident de votre
femme en 1 heure du matin
vous êtes resté dans toute la journée a
sonné par le choc et le soir vous avez
décidé d'en finir ce sont vos propres
termes
j'avais pas l'oeil vissé sur ma montre
souvent le soir la conscience ne monte
pas sa préférée ah oui vous auriez voulu
faire semblant de vous suicider
nous y seriez pas pris autrement
pourquoi j'aurais voulu faire semblant
de me suicider la question est notre
réponse idiote
cela supposerait que votre chagrin lui
aussi aurait dissimulé et pourquoi mon
chagrin lui aussi aurait été simulées je
sais pas moi bon alors on se boit du
champagne doit être fait maintenant
valider
le cesu
[Musique]
c'est pas une fille pour mon nom
sans coup dé manille
non contente d'une personne n'était pas
si on sait ce qu'elle fait comme travail
[Musique]
esthéticienne au sprint ça
je suis
oui c'est le mot sous une ficelle super
sain mais c'est pourquoi j'aime peindre
[Musique]
dis moi mon premier petit jeune montois
mentor je sais bien faire là dedans et
c'est vrai riche et crémeux francs je
suis même plus à ce qu'elle a raconté en
corse elles n'ont rien non dix mois plus
tôt pourquoi tu aimes les gars qu'est ce
que tu veux trop comme c'est joli à
regarder ça bouge ça chez toi excitant
c'est mal
[Musique]
et hier ce
c'était mon premier chamond au début son
histoire elle jardel inconscient quand
je m'en suis un peu de sous ça m'a mis
ko les toits ma place
mais après tu t'habitues 6 et 8 bat aby
du g8 qui ont sévi tu agis à la musique
mais allemand c'est un sentiment positif
piment et rapport à juin ça donne une
espèce de vitalité et didon moi moi moi
je croyais que tu avais appris
l'infidélité de sa femme après le mort
de jarden tu vois quand tu veux pas or
c'est curieux parce que terre de 1100
ans que tu étais déjà au cours avancés
contre ce que je comprends qu'une
maintenant c'est parce que quand j'ai
trouvé une lettre et qu'ils ont a
confirmé mes soupçons et c'est qu'on a
fait j'ai brûlé
beaucoup même mais jardel s'était
pourtant pas le genre de type à avec
réal et d'amour mais vous croire gossip
et tapha mais les banques et tout ça ou
peu je vous dis presque jamais mais non
mais quand je rentre à paris j'ai trouvé
des papiers qui lui appartenait et puis
j'ai tourné là-bas et j'ai fait le tri
[Musique]
un amour chèque
dis moi ils sont bien gentils les
gendarmes mais ils se cassent vraiment
pas la tronche échec et mat
pourquoi il cela casserait
il
je sors du casino à 2 heures du matin
elle est déjà bourré trois témoins
confiant 1 2 et 3 l'ado d'écart carte
colette vous qui est justement j'étais
inquiète de la voir prendre le volant
dans cet état pour faire une route de
montagne
j'ai essayé de la dissuader elle m'a
répondu qu'elle se sentait très bien
[Musique]
elle n'a pas vu la coulée de terre et
l'a freiné trop tard et trop fort dans
le virage
elle a dérapé et glissé dans le ravin la
voiture a été découverte à 5 heures du
matin par un routier voilà c'est
l'excellente est vraiment pas pourquoi
tu t'excites là dessus guyomard je vais
prendre le premier avion pour genève
oui tu diras à mes nautique nous devons
le dossier d'accident
ce qui met tout le monde sur la sphère
faut absolument qu'ils me retrouve des
témoignages sur place deux mois de
distance amusée
secundo tu demanderas l'exhumation du
corps et le top 6 je veux savoir de quoi
les morts je peux te dire d'un
traumatisme crânien d'une hémorragie
d'un coup de karaté sur la nuque
on ruine leurs études pourquoi il aurait
pu
pour épouser la petite île pouvait
divorcer millions de ménages de marché
principal en attendant celle des rebonds
de ne pas sa fille un divorce et 9 g
concevable mais la petite c'est après
qu'il en est tombé amoureux chez qu'est
ce que t'en sais toi là il se bat depuis
toujours ses gosses alors pourquoi il a
épousé yvelines un accident de parcours
ok les larmes étaient par un autre
accident simulé celui ci est suivi d'un
suicide également simulées de manière à
ce que personne ne puisse le soupçonner
c'est tout à fait dans son style
seulement ce qu'il n'avait pas prévu
mais pousse c'est que jardel se ferait
tuer que je soupçonnerait du meurtre que
je douterais demi conclusion que je
préfère une seconde enquête en vue de
discuter et qu'elle me mettrai sur les
traces du premier meurtre le break celui
là
à pau
mais ce meurtre suppose que la petite
soit complice mais pas forcément il pu
le voir jouer même comédie qu aux autres
la saq servait la soi-disant découverte
des prétendus let elles rendaient
vraisemblable son revirement subit un
peu compliqué non guillaume et crime
parfait son arme ans c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qui sont rarement parfait
y'a pas de secret au seulement laisser
mijoter le temps nécessaire dans un
stand aux plaintes du vin blanc c'est
natacha oui voila je suis content c'est
certainement la bonne méthode c'est bien
moi j'en ai marre de me jeter
si je commence à accra même tout à
l'heure au téléphone ne m'avait dit vous
avez quelque chose de très important à
m'annoncer oui une nouvelle qui vaut
concerne j'ai rouvert le dossier de
l'accident d'autres femmes pourquoi faut
vraiment est attendu dans votre genre
pour s'imaginer qu'il ya quelque chose
de louche dans cet accident mais à
première vue seulement voilà je vais
passer tout yvonne au peigne fin
non mais finit par retrouver un témoin
un témoin un témoin de quoi le portier
d'hôtel du parc a vu votre femme chargée
quelqu'un bord de sa voiture quelques
instants avant l'accident
quelqu'un qui quelqu'un qu'elle
connaissait une sur ce point de témoins
formelle pour le reste n'a rien pilotes
possibles des nues mais comment se
fait-il qu'il n'ait pas fait une
déposition à la police le lendemain
matin basque bug personne n'avait la
moindre est jeune très jeune amar avec
votre porsche
vous êtes à 4h de divonne pourrait bien
faire tourner à la nuit vous êtes un
dangereux maniaque
alors qu'on en quinze jours vous essayé
de me coller leur de jardel sur le dos
nous apercevons que ça marchait pas le
matin que vous dites c'est pas possible
il a dû tuer quelqu'un d'autre on prend
le même et on recommence
il est monté en bouc ma parole il dit
que vous pouviez avoir tué votre femme
est venue tout de suite
et que j'ai connu l'existence de joël
vous préférez vous laisser mettre en
prison plutôt que de parler d'âge
il fallait tout de même que vous ayez de
sérieuses raisons non tout quelles
raisons à ça vous voyez certainement me
le dire mais je tente pas trop là dessus
voyez ça recommence vous posez les
questions est vrai qu'on est à ma place
non non non mais rassurez vous j'ai
finira bien par se savoir
j'ai fait des progrès énormes à notre
contact
les progrès en quoi au karaté voilà
franchement je voudrais pas vous
décevoir mais vous avez encore beaucoup
à apprendre
oui le secret des arts martiaux c'est
que pour vaincre il faut renoncer à
gagner et vous n'en est pas encore là
cela dit votre choucroute
elle était pas terrible bon bah moi
sûrement se revoir
[Musique]
il ya peut-être raison peut-être que tu
es vraiment un maniaque
c'est toujours trop en fait après tout
sur quoi ça repose tout un truc sur une
mèche de cheveux tu va tout de même pas
l'envoyer aux assises pour une mèche de
cheveux ou non en plus ce n'est pas
qu'ils appartiennent au chievo turquie
soit joëlle les a expertisés à écoute
bon allez viens de relire est ce que moi
je me lève dans deux heures je suis
fatigué nom des cheveux aussi longs ou
ciblant aussi soyeux ça peut à partir
d'un cas une fille très jeune une
nordique est ce que tu as dit
je n'ai rien dit du tout je te signale
que c'est pas tout ça mais qu'est ce que
j'ai dit mon dieu
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est vous avez les clés
de l'atelier de monsieur oui pourquoi
je
[Musique]
m6 dément vous êtes collants alors mes
enfants leur a gentiment que j'appelle
un car de police
[Musique]
bon quel de vous ne commence après le
cas là deux d'ivan on a fait la tournée
en italie 20 juin quand on a tous
compris à paris j'ai profité du premier
bouquet
[Musique]
oui puisque dès l'hiver ici te voir
regarde moi tu vois c'est pas très
brillant
on peut pas te laisser démolir tu vaux
mieux que ça
tu crois qu'elle a souffert certainement
pas on n'a pas eu le temps
mais pourquoi vous l'avez laissé monté
dans cette voiture c'est le terrain qui
ces personnes a fait attention
je suis passé chez toi paris on m'a dit
que tu avais fait des coloris rassure
toi le plus dur est passé
enfin j'espère qui sait que tu peux
compter sur moi je te remercie mais tu
peux pas m'aider si peut-être veut
partir en vacances juste après on avait
dit qu'on viendra en corse
ça fait des années que l'on avait envie
l'avait dit qu'on aura une maison près
d'un torrent samedi dernier à ses excuse
moi tu vois je crois que tu ferais mieux
de me laisser seul moi je te promets que
je recommencerai pas je regarderai
demain matin tu peux me coucher
il faut que je te parle d'un art et
c'est difficile
j'ai beaucoup hésité on fait ce que je
vais faire c'est assez dégueulasse mais
je peux envie de voir du torturé pendant
des années parce que je te connais un
chagrin d'amour n'a pas fini d'en faire
une montagne
ça va prendre des proportions
gigantesques tanqueray verra si je fais
pas quelque chose de dire la vérité
regarde moi ça va faire mal très mal sur
le coup et après serrières mieux tu
verras et si tu veux je t'aiderai
acquérir le de quoi parles-tu nom de
dieu eve limiter la maîtrise du jardin
du pee wee mois bien sûr tout le monde
le savait à part toi alors la mise en
corse le torrent les vacances d'amoureux
pis dans tout ça les des folles de lui
c'est pas vrai elle se préparait de
quitter c'est pas vrai c'est pas
possible
hermine a dit
pleurant bon coup ça te faire du bien
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce que c'est c'est la petite bon
tu vas en attendant la champagne est ce
que tu as merci jaune non j'ai eu assez
de mal à tirer
je veux faire quelque chose fous l'camp
petit monde mais attends tueront pas le
français
[Musique]
tu sais je peux bien te l'avouer ça
faisait un bout de temps que j'en avais
envie
c'est pourquoi tu n'as pas dû plutôt non
pas question
j'étais la meilleure amie de feeling on
a des principes
et toi ce que je me ferais à non pas du
tout en [ __ ] il faut pas m'en vouloir
moi j'étais complètement intoxiqué et ça
tape tu m'as fait la même impression que
si je sortais de prison qui sait la
petite blonde est une amie d'enfance
dans le genre cola on fait pas mieux est
amoureuse de toi non salut passera que
c'est banach pour nous deux tu pas envie
que ce soit juste une fois comme ça je
voudrais qu'on fasse un petit bout de
chemin ensemble un petit cran bout
qu'est ce que tu en penses
moi tu sais le grand amour je suis pas
très chaud sorte en prendre moi fera pas
comme avec avignon
j'ai des projets mois des grands projets
des trucs qu'on peut faire 4-2 par
exemple bien diriger une maison de
culture je te verrais très bien jardel
j'essaye de même beaucoup mieux que lui
tu as beaucoup plus de talent et moi je
m'occuperai du côté plus mannequin tout
ça ça serait pas extra je peux rester
moelleux rêveur mais c'est pas un rêve
c'est quoi c'est une possibilité qu'il
repose sur quoi qui repose sur la soirée
d animer la soirée de 20 8 mais j'ai
gagné plein de prix commence à au casino
d'yvan à roulettes nom d'art
on apporte alors votre chagrin d'amour
c'était sincère
tout ce que je vous ai dis était vrai je
vous ai jamais menti ni sauf en ce qui
concerne l'om ne pas dire certaines
choses c'est pas forcément mentir même
écouter j'avais à peine le temps de
répondre aux questions que vous me
posiez je pouvais pas en plus répondre à
celles que vous ne pouviez pas bon bon
alors revenons à divo
à quelle heure et vous sortie du casino
à deux heures le matin avec les autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
mystique grossiste allemand extrême
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après on n'est pas 3000
vous
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
oh non non les gars de l'abus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a commencé tout petit un jour elle
demande l augmentation lendemain elle
exige est passé mannequin vedette le
coup de chance pour l accélération
foudroyante ça a été la mort de jardel
peu un peu elle a parlé d'association
bénéfices
- at-c
je pouvais réactif
et m
alors j'ai mieux
que s'est il passé exactement dans la
voiture
[Musique]
germaine thibal à huy alors pourquoi
attendez-vous s'appuie bise on m'a
raconté pour mon dieu
les jours je sais pas mais pas nul
j'ai divorcé
on a décidé ça à la fois
tu peux rien que lot comme j'aime
laisser faire on répare nîmois le topo
de la femme qui a sacrifié sa vie à la
grande rade de son patron de toute façon
je pouvais continuer à travailler avec
lui moi j'ai rien contre
[Musique]
descendez du détaillant les buts comme
toi il semble qu'apple à 12 à 10 ans
après d'autres encore et c'est justement
ça qui mesurent toi ça allait toujours
elle est peut-être allez-vous faire
remonter la poya ribavirine chez moi
[Musique]
à
tu peux pas
[Musique]
à
ou pas
[Musique]
à